You know, I'm glad you're here, Andy.
'Cause let's face it, this
is a very strange time.
Very much so, yeah.
It's such a very
strange time, and it's a confusing time.
Because during COVID,
we're being bombarded
with information.
You know, you turn on any TV,
you go on your computer,
and they're gonna show you graphs.
Now some of these graphs are important.
But here's what I'm noticing.
A lot of the graphs that
are coming out lately
don't seem that necessary.
Have you noticed that?
Absolutely, yeah.
A lot of silly stuff.
Yeah, you know?
For example, I mean, some of these charts
are, I don't know, they
just seem questionable.
Here's a chart that came out today.
There's apparently been a
huge increase in second naps.
Okay.
Look at this, there's been a
400% increase in day drinking.
[Andy] I'm drunk now!
I know, I could tell.
Yeah.
That's a good reason to
sit far away from me,
is the smell.
Yeah.
I got a little closer to you earlier,
and I just smelled bathtub gin.
Yep, yep.
Check this graph out.
There's been a steady increase of
watching another God damn show on Netflix.
I guess.
Look at this one, this is
not a surprising chart.
But I don't know that we
needed to see this one.
Check it out.
Here's the national rate of masturbation.
Okay, is that a chart we needed to see?
I dunno, I'm kinda getting
off on it. (chuckles)
I'm kinda getting off on it.
Okay, take it easy.
Yeah, yeah.
'Cause you know, the graph is going whoop.
All right, all right.
Probably add a little bit
of a slide whistle sound.
Whoop!
That's, oh, yeah.
Glad you're here!
It's Randy?
It can be, I don't care!
Okay.
Of course, a sharp rise in dads shouting,
"I used to be a very powerful man!"
here's the latest graph on time.
Didn't really help me much to see that.
They've also been tracking divorces
by spouses married to COVID graph makers.
Little meta, but--
Oh boy, that's a sad one.
Yeah, here's an interesting one.
What we talk about with our walls.
There's what's it like being a wall?
How was your day?
And wall, you're my only friend.
I say that a lot.
Here's a graph I actually
find kinda fascinating.
Sharp increase of frat
brothers in Alabama,
saying "Oh man, did you hear about Tre?"
(Andy laughs)
Tre made a mistake.
Poor Tre.
And finally, given all the other data
that's out there, here's our last graph.
It's one showing hope.
Always fun to end a comedy
bit on a happy note!
Yeah!
All right, go out on a bummer!
Yeah, hey Andy, do me a favor.
Do what our audience back in Burbank
would usually do.
Oh, all right.
It's my birthday!
(Conan laughs)
I want a hug!
(Andy laughs)
Do the string dance!
Yeah, yeah, the T-shirt
cannon broke my teeth!
(Conan laughs)
Yep, we do miss our crowds, though.
We do.
They're some of the
best people in Burbank.
(Conan chuckles)